[Music]
breeders are retro breeding dogs to
prevent breathing problems what's retro
breed is this a poem
it's a haiku say this five times
[Laughter]
breathing backwards like finding the old
lines right yeah exactly so pretty much
uh you guys are familiar with like um
[ __ ] uh one of the drummers
and stuff yeah right bulldogs super
super short oh yeah over the years you
look more shrunk like a crushed cat
which is cute and everybody loves this
[ __ ] right but then they [ __ ] have
huge breathing problems yeah they're
always wheezing they die really really
young
yellow
brachiocephalic breath
we got all the science names yep i know
it means shortened head yeah yeah um but
retro breeding would be going the other
way so finding the uh more close to the
authentic genetic line and getting
closer back to the original so it's
almost like bringing the purebreds back
into the game in order to not have it be
so [ __ ] up like german shepherds every
fifth generation they uh re-breed wolf
back in what
that's how they keep it pure to have an
actual pure german show every five
generations imagine if people did if
like the big three did that and we retro
there'd be there'd be no southeast
asians yeah probably there'd be none
it'd only only be chinese japanese
koreans
need to get this spaniard out of my
filipino man
they made us have last names that's
whack
i was in uh we were in spain and i was
packed with one of the uh filipino
dancers in the crew right and this other
spanish dude you know one of the
students asked him was like hey so he's
like you're filipino but
why is your last name cruz
and pat's like uh because all you
spaniards came and raped us a long time
ago and he's like oh yeah yeah you're
right
but i think it was mexico wasn't it
because they're closer i don't think it
was spain oh yeah it was spain
but let's be honest though it's all the
same thing because they all speak to
contain languages so spanish they're all
colonized by the same group yeah yeah i
mean breeding in general that's that's
just a fun topic obviously when we do it
without maybe not fun is the right
interesting choice
process is fun the process is
interesting sex is good right it's like
it's like how people were talking about
like yao meaning and [ __ ] like that
right with chinese people they're just
constantly trying to breed like to talk
and his wife's like six four some [ __ ]
is she oh damn yeah
but when it's love it's like that one
dude
well what wasn't that that one dude on
[ __ ] rocky the the russian dude he
was like drago drago was a russian
experiment dolph lundgren yeah
he's a russian so he has a phd and i
think chemistry or chemical engineering
does he really yeah
interesting story with them we had just
gotten to college it was like
orientation week so it was our first
experience as like you know like in
college they let us go so we we went to
westwood and we watched showdown in
little tokyo i loved that movie
underrated bro underrated i didn't watch
it see your career best line in that
movie i saw you coming yeah i heard i
heard you come that time you know i was
like that's some powerful car that's
amazing right but then my friend he
comes back from the bathroom because you
guys don't look right now but dolph
lundgren's right behind us shut up dude
we look and sure enough there's dolph
lundgren and he's huge so his knees are
like touching like the seats in front
he's with this girl with bodyguards he's
watching his own movie yeah so i don't
know if he didn't go to the premiere or
he didn't see or i don't know what but
he's there in westwood he's like two
hours behind us oh in the old the the
little city yeah yeah yeah and then when
that line came up like you know at that
time i heard you come no one laughed
because he's right behind us yeah so
we're just like
really you guys didn't play it up oh
dude we were like i mean
we felt like adults but we were a little
kid we were just out of high school and
dolph lung was like what 6 20 you know
like
and we're just like
like you know we didn't want to like you
know we're like what the hell dude but
that that was our show around the tokyo
experience it was awesome
so for context there's a part in the
movie where like because he's just like
uh obviously like really good
professional combat guy and he tells
them like oh like he shocked her because
she didn't know that he was there and
he's like oh you'll never hear me coming
and then later on they have sex and she
goes i heard you coming that time yeah
yeah yeah yeah
this is the greatest [ __ ] but we
couldn't laugh so that was unhealthy for
us because we couldn't laugh because two
rows down is the powerful comer
yeah but it was supposed to be a joke
yeah but no but you know anyone
disrespecting i don't want to disrespect
dolph lundgren you know he's just
laughing by himself with the bodyguards
you laugh he goes what's so funny
oh dolph hello being as huge as he is
his face must be you just like coming
over yeah
especially because you guys were younger
and smashed i know we're like you know
it was like it was like three korean
people and uh one white guy
and we're all small like you know high
school kids those are just awesome odds
that you just decided to go watch it
during orientation
and he's there yeah that's nuts wow
because he would have seen it at the
premiere the movie had already premiered
that's crazy maybe he went to the apron
didn't watch the movie he wanted to see
it or maybe like that girl
is new and he's like oh you know why
don't you you know what i do no i do
this
i come really loud
maybe you already seen it but like you
wanted to see how real people
reacted and you know and then nobody
laughs no one laughs
look this is the funniest part listen
listen no one laughs and you know when
tia curse of that you know he nudged her
yeah yeah
later later
[Laughter]
you're gonna find out isn't it crazy
like just knowing where that was shot
like right here downtown l.a yeah and
then like some of the people actually
i've probably seen them at a film
festival or something like um
that one girl the japanese girl
uh
[ __ ] what's her name she was in the
movie but she's always at the uh at
those events and [ __ ] isn't the final
fight scene on like first street
like in showdown little tokyo where the
parade was yeah yeah yeah it's like
right there in front of the japanese
american museum yup that's right there
dude bart's never even seen it you never
saw it you'd love it i need to watch it
have you seen big trouble in little
china is that when the guy
gets inflated like he yeah
mr burton
you know they're remaking that no way it
better be racist
it's not going to be the same were we
making big trouble how do you even make
it while being careful about race i
don't understand how you even make it
yeah because it was hella racist back
then but it's hilarious how bad it was
yeah to me it when they made movies
about asian [ __ ] back then it was like
panda express
it was like fake china yeah it was like
fake asian [ __ ] it was still delicious
you could totally tell it was like a
jewish writer who went to a chinese
restaurant to get an inspiration and
that's all he [ __ ] knew and then he
made a film yeah
did you guys remember the last dragon
yes yeah so good the best the best
collection of scenes is when they show
the chinese guys talking black and
acting black and then uh
leroy like he's just
a black guy but who's roofing but he
acts asian yeah
that i think it was great because if you
didn't they never pointed it out it's
just you just had to pick it up like you
know these chinese guys were acting
black and this black guy's acting
chinese yeah is the best yeah and then
the best scene is when his brother gets
tied up but he pops to get out
the ropes get all loose easel
let's tie you guys up and let's see how
it works we're going to tie these
[ __ ] because i was a little kid
when i saw it you know i was on theater
and i was like oh that's why popping is
dope because if someone ever told me i
could get
as a kid you believe the kung fu movies
like you believe if you do this on
someone you're gonna break skin they're
gonna die yeah you're gonna break skin
and all that that interaction is like
lost in history they need to use that
asian to black interaction more today as
a lesson because it's dope yeah you guys
ever seen kung fu movies dubbed with
black people
is that
when i was young it was black belt
theater and kung fu theater every
saturday they played two kung fu movies
then when that kind of died down i want
to say like in the 90s
they started dubbing the kung fu movies
with black people
in their accent it's hilarious damn is
that why wu-tang clan came up and liked
that [ __ ] is that why in that bruce lee
movie the dudes are you ever heard of
chinese oh my god
that was a chinese guy it became like a
stereotypical black voice like to be
like you never heard of that well let me
show you and he sucks him in the stomach
yeah well let me show you
we're like and he's so cool in that
movie bro
when they're in rome that one right
there at the restaurant
i was like how did these guys end up in
rome that's my question how did this
whole crew end up in russia i'm not
speaking italian yeah
yeah they're bullies chinese dudes i
know what's the prequel of just their
lives
i think i want to do some traveling baby
that's exactly the you know the funny
thing when you mention that is that when
i was a kid and watch kung fu movies i
thought that's how chinese people spoke
because as a kid i didn't know what
dubbing was yeah to me it's just it's
just so you thought they spoke like
black guy your kung fu is very good like
i just thought that's how china will
talk i didn't know it was dubbing then
when i saw a documentary when i was a
little bit older i was like oh these are
white guys doing this i had no idea
i had no idea that that's
i just thought if i went to china that's
how they would all talk and then their
lips don't match
passport please baby
i got the game oh [ __ ] the black guy
and then i used to think like you know
when they punch you know the dust would
come from their clothes yeah it's to
show how fast they're punching i just
thought y'all were dirty like i didn't
know how to show them i didn't know
that's what that would be
that's what they had to do back then
dirty clothes dude they're all dusty and
[ __ ]
why are they
people are like [ __ ] fossils bro
[ __ ] dusty yeah like as a kid though
because you know you don't if you if if
you explain dubbing to a kid they're not
gonna understand yeah i didn't
understand it either so to me you think
they talk like that that's why i just
thought that's such a good talk i didn't
know about chinese accents or anyone's
accent i just thought that that's what
it was if i went to china they'd all be
like
[Laughter]
people got a taste of it now with a
squid game because some people watched
it with the uh english which is like hey
why are you guys even doing that but
it's like people are like oh yeah did
you guys see do you guys watch in
english and i'm like no [ __ ] way
you're supposed to watch them just read
the subtitles subtitles dude [ __ ]
losers i know people don't want to
read i don't want to i don't want to
read what i watch kick rocks dude kick
rocks like they just that's just code
for i can't read fast enough yeah yeah
they put their finger on the tv and [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] sounding out worse
two hours
we're gonna go back
that's hilarious hey what are you doing
well i usually chase my finger
i can't do something with comedy though
right because it gives away the
punchline behind me and the punchline
you can't do that i'm not going to give
up i don't like that too that's why the
good the good subtitlers they'll they'll
pause the subtitle
and then match it with the voice that's
true but that's rare how do you how do
you watch steven chow movies because
that's comedy they hit differently
though i think but dubbing dubbing is is
just the worst it's the lesser of two
evils so comedic timing or dubbing if
it's a cantonese movie that is worse
because cantonese comedy delivery is
[ __ ] amazing i don't even know what
they're saying but the delivery is fun
point yeah but a lot of it is on
slapstick too so oh yeah that's true but
like you know for like hentai porn
like i don't like i don't like uh
subtitles i'd rather have dubbing
because there's just too many things i
have to do you're jacking a you're what
you're trying to follow a story i mean
in any porn
any kind of subtitles kind of but it
kind of works because all cartoons
dubbing anyway yeah i'm trying to jack
off and then you don't have a finger to
[ __ ] put it in the middle yeah
because you can't you're like oh like
i'm tired oh okay but you're not used to
trying this
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i
what if you forget you came already and
it's like you're like still tracking
because you want the story the story is
really good and it's like dripping off
your finger
your mom's calling you to come eat
you're like i don't know what to do it's
a logistics nightmare i can't do that
but what if the dubbing is the same
quality as an old chinese movie in the
porn oh man that's weird heard you had a
leak baby
oh god oh this is daryl this guy again
why are they talking like that
it's the same guy
he's still alive
he's gonna be a black guy from the seven
days he's still getting work
you